michael walker's toyota numbers in his
first two starts his last start against
atlanta he was jumped for five two out
runs in the first two innings likes
pitching on this mound though his only
complete game shutout in the regular
season came here in 2017.
somebody closed the door that's very far
were you born in a barn
jonathan vr leads off for the marlin
and he finally gets vr on the ninth
pitch of the advantage it looks like his
fastball has electricity a lot of life
yeah he's pumped up here in the early
going
[Applause]
there's a nasty change up to get alvarez
and he's got back-to-back strikeouts to
start the night
so two out of nobody on now corey
dickerson 2-2 to dickerson
and he gets him swinging
michael walka strikes out the sign of
the opening inning a changeup what a
weapon dumberto mejia who makes his
major league debut marlins picked him up
from the alternate side he's been with
his organization since september of
2013.
three and two and the first big league
strikeout for umberto mejia retires
brandon nimmo and there's one out he's
got a chance to strike out the side if
he can get the d.a pete alonzo
he drives one out to center field going
back his sierra onto the warning track
back at the wall it's off the fence in
play alonzo to second and he'll pull in
there with a long double and now michael
conforto
and he went around so works around the
double and picks up the first three
strikeouts of his career
here comes matt joyce looking for his
first big league hit of this season two
goals two strikes with andy off of first
here it comes from waka
over the mound rosario has to adjust
bear hands it and safe at first and a
chance here to crack the scoreboard
first the first one to cervelli
is high in the air to deep right field
it sends conforto way back and gone a
three-run home run to the opposite field
for francisco cervelli i think that'll
qualify as a big hit right hey
love the approach the big guy came in
with the best numbers against wakka
wakka looks different this inning to me
marlins have another base runner it's a
second walk given up in the inning by
michael walker
and vr out toward left center field
gonna get down
sierra has got the wheels he's around
third base vr into second with an rbi
double and the marlins have a four
nothing lead now we'll see how he does
after sitting in the dugout for a long
time
floating rules as dom smith hits it deep
to right and forget that dominic smith
gets the minutes on the board up into
the coca-cola corner
his second home run of the year and it
cuts the marlins lead to four to one as
he parks one in the second deck to get
the mets on the board he's the first
hitter who wasn't beat by that fastball
up and in and here's andres jimenez
oh that one looked good another
strikeout for mejia that is four and
there are two outs in the second
and rosario gets a curveball for strike
three called so he did the same to
rosario that he did to jimenez that was
something hellacious scare there's
aguilar the dh today
it's a 2-0 pitch big swing and a fly
ball well hit center field nimmo going
back kind of got turned around and he
can't make the catch it lands on the
warning track and bounces up against the
wall aguilar who had swung so hard he
fell down initially picked himself up
ends up at second base with a double
and joyce takes the change up for strike
three call so wahka comes back after the
double and strikes out anderson and
joyce to get through the top of the
third five strikeouts for waka 4-1
marlon that's now six k's in the first
two and a third innings of umberto
mejia's big league career he's going to
be done after 67 pitches don mattingly
to the mound that is a very impressive
major league debut for young umberto
mejia
and conforto bloops one behind third
shallow left on comes dickerson he won't
get there it's a fair ball nimo to third
it gets behind dickerson nimo though
went down and he has to stay at third
base he didn't have to slide into third
base
tonight jd davis with two in scoring
position
and a called strike three so the marlins
get a break and make the most of it
sierra is on base for the third time
then homer at the next game shreve picks
him off and sierra in the world great
pickup by rosario and he makes the tag
tom smith with the low throw and rosario
saved him with a gorgeous pick and it's
a one three six caught stealing so blyer
comes in walks his first batter
and mcneal will come to bat as the tying
run
mcneil line caught by alvarez at second
how do you like that an olympian speed
skater
goes with the high jump to take away an
extra base hit there was no
more room left and the mets have the
bases loaded with one out with conforto
coming up conforto gets another crack at
one and he takes one the other way on
one hop snagged at third point
rosario scores everybody else goes up a
base and it's four to two
brian anderson fielded it cleanly but
made a terrible throw home oh my god
that enables rosario to score to get the
mets within two and the mets have a
chance in the bottom of the eighth down
four to two
jd lines one on the left field for a
base hit dozier comes in alonzo will be
held at third as dickerson gets it in
it's an rbi single for jd davis to pull
the mets within a run it's now four to
three now the inning rests in the hands
of wilson ramos
and alvarez
finds it gets it to first and has just
enough time but the marlins maintain
their lead
and the mets are down to their final out
of the night this game rests on the
shoulders of billy hamilton
[Applause]
this one out too
in a sliding catch for corey dickerson
it's a marlins win miami keeps it going
with another w